ah here we are running in a horror game
again when are they gonna start putting
checkpoints in these games find a note
there supposed to be a note yeah you
think being the most subscribed in
YouTube would help all right there's a
pooper let's go to the pooper
the pooper is the answer laughs okay
Darsh line my god the seal hope rose
there's still hope for our cake let it
go let it go man yeah yeah oh my god I
got a high-five myself a catch I'm to
retire I'm too stupid I can't I can't
believe I saw Kim Kardashian good for
you good for you yes I can Canadian good
for you good for you good for you get
you I get for you kids for you good for
you good for you all right
you know what we're gonna have to expand
here I think it's about time that we
kill some yes oh my god this is gonna be
awesome
I got it no why did I do that
no Lacey what are you doing here
Oh